[Music]
[Applause]
uh Andy Staples covers college football
for on three Sports and he was in
Tuscaloosa Saturday for Alabama as
comeback win over Tennessee he'll be in
Jacksonville next Saturday Georgia and
Florida I'll get to Alabama Tennessee in
a moment uh worst loss of the college
football weekend was turned in by who
Andy North Carolina losing to a one and5
Virginia North Carolina was was in a
position it felt like they were
potentially going to be undefeated going
to the ACC Championship game to play
Florida state that the path was there
for them and you know it looked like
North car had improved defensively but
they just laid an egg against a team
that that they should have been able to
beat pretty handily so that was that was
by far the worst one yeah but you know
North Carolina does this it feels like
every other year where you go hey North
Carolina got a nice little team there
then all of a sudden you're losing to
Virginia where does USC's home loss to
Utah ranked it's bad it's bad but I mean
that's the third consecutive loss by USC
to Utah we should be getting used to
this by now uh but I you mentioned that
you have bill plashy on the show Bill
hit it on the head that's exactly how
people in Los Angeles are feeling right
now is this was supposed to be different
this was supposed to be better you know
I I wrote a column off the Pack 12
championship game last year in Vegas
where Utah just demolished USC once
Caleb Williams got dinged up Utah took
advantage of of USC having a defense
that couldn't tackle and he said okay
this off season they will make this
better they will improve the talent on
the defense they will improve the scheme
it will get better it didn't get any
better they did improve the talent but
for whatever reason you've got Bryson
Barnes who was not expected to be Utah's
starter uh he's a walk- on who was a
backup to cam Rising but cam rising's
not coming back because of his knee you
got Bryson bars running through USC's
defense to set up a game-winning field
goal it's just every week it's the same
thing and I I think we kind of knew when
USC played Colorado and we saw that
Colorado offense pick USC's defense
apart in the second half it's like okay
this is gonna be a little bit rough and
it's it's gonna get worse because
they've still got to play Washington and
Oregon where do you stand with u Lincoln
Riley's future at
USC well he he can stay there as long as
he wants the question is does he want to
compete for national titles there
because if he does he's going to have to
make some changes this is the same stuff
that a lot of people have been
saying going back to Oklahoma you have
got to make physical play a bigger
priority in your program you've got to
practice differently you got to have a
different philosophy about that they're
probably going to have to change
defensive coordinators in the offseason
and and move on from Alex Grinch but you
have to be able to tackle at some point
it can't just be pretty plays where the
quarterback makes some magic happen and
by the way Caleb Williams will be gone
next year now I trust Lincoln Riley to
always have a good quarterback because
he always has but they have to have a
better offensive line and a better
defensive line where they're going
they're going to the big 10 you know you
you're playing Michigan you're playing
Ohio State Penn State those teams do not
care how pretty your plays are they're
just GNA punch you in the mouth and
that's the part that I I
don't I don't understand how he hasn't
figured that out yet because it's pretty
clear that what Kirby Smart does and
what Jim Harbaugh does the way they
practice the way they play that wins and
wins at a high level like what Nick sain
does wins at a high
level I think Jim Harbaugh had a pretty
good weekend when you consider the walls
were kind of closing in on him a little
bit there with the sign stealing and
then you know his quarterback is you
know according to DraftKings he's the
leading candidate for the Heisman feels
like and Harbaugh may have the best team
in college football most balanced team
in college football where do you stand
on Michigan and their placement among
the hierarchy oh they're fantastic and
and you may be right they may be the
best team in college football we won't
know until they actually play somebody
which we won't see that till November
11th when they go to State College and
play Penn State but they absolutely are
built perfectly based on you know you
look at who's going to the NFL from that
roster
uh how much talent have they accumulated
who's good where they have the most
special quarterback that they've had in
the Jim Harbaugh era and he keeps saying
that over and over about J.J McCarthy
he's the most dynamic quarterback Jim
Harbaugh's had in Michigan so they
absolutely have everything they need we
just need to see them play somebody good
unfortunately the schedule worked out
the way it worked out if this were next
year they would have better opponents
coming in sooner and we'd have a better
idea of what they are but we got to deal
with what we got and I I can't wait to
see them against Penn State now Penn
State did not blow us away in Columbus
the the the offense is not very good the
defense is but at least we'll get to see
what that Michigan offense looks like
against an elite defense and I think
that will help us kind of Judge where
they fit along with everybody else we're
talking to Andy Staples he covers
college football for on three Sports
will the regular season be
deemphasized next
season no because they're going to be
games that aren't ma that don't matter
now that are going to matter quite a bit
now will for example Penn State Ohio
State feel like the be allend all type
game no but it wasn't this year really
either because Penn State if they were
to beat Michigan is not out of them is
not out of the hunt now so what's going
to happen though is you're gonna have
games among teams that are trying to be
the number 12 team or the number 11 team
you're going to have games between teams
that are trying to be the number nine
team or the number eight team because
that matters if you're number nine you
go on the road if you're number eight
you start at home they're going to be
you know conference championships will
still matter because you've got to win
one to get a Buy in the playoffs so all
of that stuff will still matter it's not
going to deemphasize anything there'll
be more games that actually matter for
the season longer into the season and
for more teams yeah when I was pushing
for this 12 team playoff I got some
blowback from people saying hey it's
going to ruin the regular season I go no
now all of a sudden you can have two
losses and still get into the playoffs
here um and and if you're looking at
this year that's not going to happen but
it does make the November games more
important as opposed to hey we're just
going to play and see if we're bull
eligible or you know uh we we might be a
spoiler here now you have a legitimate
chance with these these teams there's
going to be more teams more games that
are more more important uh or mean
something than November's usually a
throwaway month for a lot of these
schools cuz they're not going for entire
conferences sometimes Dan like there
were years where the big 12 or the Pack
12 was effectively eliminated by
November that's not any fun now now the
Pack 12 eliminated Itself by getting
torn apart but now like in the Big 12
you're gonna have a bunch of teams that
are all pretty similar all very
competitive with one another and there's
going to be at least at least one spot
for them out there and possibly two or
more and think about what those games
will be like down the stretch where you
could have you know a team take over
first place this week lose next week get
it back the following week it's going to
be fun always great to talk to you Andy
safe travels to Jacksonville for Georgia
and
Florida thank you Dan Andy Staples been
covering college football for a long
time